[Musique]
sur les murs à nombre de nous-mêmes ce
thème un bon jour le
but
[Musique]
est d'adapter
si tu veux perdre 28 euros tous les deux
semaines surtout pas cette vidéo tu vois
là lui avec sa tronche de cake et ben il
va tous les deux semaines chez le
coiffeur alors qu'à pas un poil sur le
caillou games explique même de quoi
faire quand ils voient arriver comprends
pas tu aimais sport compte à linverse tu
vas chez l'esthéticienne tous les trois
mois alors que tu te ferait bien d'aller
tous les deux semaines parce que plus la
salle de jeux
non
il veut
non oh
[Musique]
il
colas 2 y'en a pas
[Musique]
mon dieu on me dit est évident que s'ils
veulent maîtriser le français
s'empare de tout ce qui est politique
non le cac 40